[تصفيق]
لذلك
لدينا حشد كبير
وسنسحق الفيروس ،
لذا
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، لم يكن أحد
يرتدي أقنعة في الغرفة
عندما كنا نستعد للرئيس
خلال تلك الفترة الزمنية
وكنا نحن المجموعة التي كانت على
وشك  خمسة أو ستة أشخاص إجمالاً
[تصفيق]
عليك أن تفهم ما إذا كنت تنظر ،
أعني أن لدي قناعًا هنا ، فأنا أضع
قناعًا عليه ، كما تعلم عندما أعتقد أنني
بحاجة إليه ، فأنا لا أرتدي فوضى مثله في كل
مرة ترى  لقد حصل على قناع
يمكن أن يتحدث عنه على بعد
200 قدم منه يظهر
بأكبر قناع رأيته في حياتي ،
شكرًا جزيلاً ، نحن ذاهبون إلى
مينيسوتا
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] ظهرت
بعض الأخبار في وقت سابق هذا المساء أه
آمل أن يكون اختبار هيكس الذي عمل معك لفترة
طويلة إيجابيًا
لفيروس كورونا وخرجت للتو مع
اختبار سأرى ما تعرفه لأننا
أمضينا الكثير من الوقت في السيدة الأولى
خرجت للتو مع اختبار
أيضًا سواء  نحن في الحجر الصحي أو ما إذا
كان لدينا لا أعرف
[موسيقى]
من الجيد أن يكون لديك مستند  كما هو الحال
دائمًا وفقط لأكون واضحًا ، أنا لا أسألك
عن علاج ترامب
لأنني على حق في أن أقترح أنه ليس لديك
أي علاقة بعلاجه ،
هذا صحيح كريس لم أكن
مشتركًا في رعايته الأولية ،
حسنًا  أه فقط خطوة واحدة إلى الأمام
من حيث القلق بشأن قائدنا العام
حتى لو كان يتحسن ، فسيتعين
عليك الاحتفاظ بالمزيد وليس عليك
، فسيتعين عليهم الاستمرار في مراقبته بشكل
صحيح فقط للتأكد من عدم وجود
بقايا
أو ثانوي  أو لفترة طويلة ، أعني أنه حتى لو كان
لديك تعويذة سريعة مع علاج تجريبي رائع ،
فلا يزال يتعين عليك القلق قليلاً
هناك ، حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، كريس بدلاً من القلق
بشأن المدى الطويل
الذي تعلم أنه يبدو جيدًا كما يمكنك أن
ترى الطريقة التي بدا بها
عندما خرج من المستشفى ،
تكمن المشكلة في أنه لا يزال
مبكرًا بما فيه الكفاية في المرض بحيث لا
يخفى على أحد
أنه إذا نظرت إلى المسار
السريري للأشخاص في بعض الأحيان عندما تكون من خمسة إلى
ثمانية
أيام ، فستتحول
الأطباء  معرفة الانعكاس الذي
يعني السير في الاتجاه الخاطئ والوقوع
في المشاكل ، فمن غير المرجح أن
يحدث ذلك ،
لكن يجب أن يكونوا على علم بذلك ، فهو
يعلم أن الأطباء يعرفون ذلك ،
لذا سيراقبون
ذلك  سأحاول القيام بذلك
داخل
حدود البيت الأبيض بدلاً من
المستشفى ، لكن نعم ،
لن تخرج منه حتى
تخرج عدة أيام وتحسن أداءك ،
لكنه بالتأكيد يبدو جيدًا جدًا ،
أعني أنك لا تفعل ذلك  لا أريد أن أخبرك
أنك رأيت الطريقة التي خرج بها من
المروحية إلى هناك ، لقد بدا
وكأنه في حالة جيدة جدًا ،
دعني أسألك شيئًا عن مدى
حجمك الآن في
علاج ريجينيرون لأن شيئًا ما ساعد في
ذلك  لقد
تغلب الرجل على المنحنى ، نعم أنت تعرف
جيدًا أنه من الممكن أن يكون ذلك يعني
أن الأجسام المضادة أحادية النسيلة كريس هي
أحد الأشياء التي
نعرفها حقًا أنك متفائل جدًا بشأن
خبرتنا
في أمراض أخرى
كان الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة واحدًا من  tw
أنواع الأجسام المضادة
التي كانت ناجحة جدًا مع الإيبولا
وحقيقة نجاحها في
الإصابة بفيروس الإيبولا ، جعلتنا عدوى فيروسية أخرى خطيرة للغاية نتفاءل بحذر
بأن الأجسام المضادة أحادية النسيلة التي هي
بروتين محدد جدًا يصنعه الجسم
ويمكن أن ينتج
بكميات كبيرة جدًا  الكميات وضخها
في الفرد عن طريق
التسريب الوريدي لديه القدرة على أن يكون
شيئًا مهمًا جدًا في
علاج
المرضى الذين يعانون من مرض covet 19 ، وقد حصل الرئيس على
ذلك باعتباره استخدامًا عطوفًا
وسواء كان ذلك هو ما
جعله أفضل أم لا.  يشك بشدة في
أنه كان كذلك
ولكن من الواضح أنه لا يمكنك إثبات ذلك حتى
تقوم بعدد من الدراسات
أو أي شيء لإثبات أنه
يعمل
بشكل جيد بالفعل ، فأنت تعلم أنه كان من
الطبيعي أن يستدير على أي حال
ولكن
عندما ترى هذا النوع  يبلغ من العمر 74 عامًا ،
تذكر
نعم ، وأنت أيضًا تتذكر أنه
كان في مصير الغرفة ، أعني إذا كنت
تسألني عن رأيي ،
نعم أعتقد أنه أحدث فرقًا ولكن
عندما يكون لديك
n يساوي واحدًا ، لا يمكنك إثبات ذلك ، لكني
أعتقد أن الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة
أحدث فرقًا وهو الآن في
تجربة سريرية
لمحاولة إثبات نجاحه إذا نجح ،
آمل أن يعمل كما
نعتقد  لكنني أعلم من التجربة أننا مررنا
بفيروس الإيبولا في إفريقيا أن الأجسام
المضادة أحادية النسيلة يمكنها حقًا إحداث ضربة قاضية
للفيروس